tourists a word a bucket-list item and
on the southeast coast of Mexico big
business life here revolves around the
2d style weather man woman or beast
there aren't male thérèse toes it's also
what they call that feeling in your gut
you get after you ingest too much of the
local water I arrived as a tourist I
headed to Cozumel or as the
straight-faced Senor selling information
upon arrival put it
Kusum el es la historia that history
goes back to the Yucatec Maya as their
civilization expanded some Mayans packed
up their language and architecture and
traveled route de Maya up to this wide
flat peninsula the Yucatan so the ruins
here are a bit younger which doesn't
stop the tourists us Chichen Itza is
about 10 times as popular as fabled de
gallo that's all history like the man
said but it's not all in the distant
past until recently the Caribbean coast
of Mexico was pretty undeveloped not
small houses with a few open lots kind
of undeveloped but fresh jungle kind of
undeveloped savage Sun Baca the very
Salva a very flat very Mayan King pan
that row became one of Mexico's two
newest states in 1974 some locals still
speak Yucatec I'm told you can even
practice the language if you get the
right person to open up I didn't have
much luck might have something to do
with my Mayan being limited to shulk and
Balaam but much like you and me
most of these smiling faces around here
flocked to these beach towns thanks to
big booty smo snorkel tours dive tours
tours to the ruins oh and don't forget
your t-shirt and wiggly turtle have fun
be safe and bring yo pesos fellow
turista
you